[Music]
[Applause]
we spoke to Pal Gasol yesterday after
the show had a chance to talk to him
about a variety of things and uh I
started out by asking him how he found
out that he was going into the Hall of
Fame
oh Jerry Colangelo called me
um and then told me the the good news
obviously I was named one of the
finalists for the class of 2023 and I
was told that I was going to get a call
at a specific on a specific day in a
specific around a specific time and um
and Jerry uh said I have good news to
give you uh you know you've been
selected to be a part of the class and
now you're in so it's pretty special
were they going to call you one way or
another whether you got in or not yes I
think so I think I think they they call
you either way from what I've heard of
other
Hall of Famers or different people that
are have been finalists but didn't get
in the first time didn't get in for or
multiple times you get that call
regardless uh so uh so it's it's good
it's great when it's uh when it's good
news
if I was going to show one highlight
in your induction ceremony give me the
Highlight that you would want shown
wow geez that is that is a good one
uh I think
um
you know
probably
you know probably one of the images or
after the buzzer goes off after game
seven of 2010 against the Celtics I
think that that that feeling
of winning that game that series that
Championship uh it's uh it's a special
one
when did it change because it used to be
European players were soft labeled soft
Dirk Nowitzki's talked to me about that
that you know when he first got into the
league they made fun of him but that
doesn't come up anymore
why no no I think we were we were able
to kind of erase that stigma uh
um by you know by performing at a high
level and and really
uh and then no luckily many other
European players or international
players have come and played at a high
level and uh now you know arguably three
or five or four of the top players in
the league are international
uh three of them being a European so so
again I think that that's that's no
longer part of the conversation uh which
is which is great I mean I had to deal
with it uh to some degree for uh some of
my career Derek I'm sure had to deal
with it to some degree as well but uh
but yeah I think we we proved that we
were competitors we were tough we
weren't just fundamentally sound and not
just players that knew how to play the
game and knew how to shoot and dribble
and pass but also competed and were
physical as well
why did you want to be a doctor
I wanted to help well first of all I
grew up in a in my family my parents my
mom being a doctor my dad being a nurse
I grew up in a medical family
um and I I felt like being able to
help people be healthier and heal people
um
I think that that was something so
powerful and important uh I always said
you know without Health we're we're
nothing right we uh we have to in order
to to enjoy life to be to be here in
this world you have to you know you have
to be healthy yeah and and doctors you
know uh help people be be healthy to
stay healthy or get healthier so uh so I
wanted to cure people I wanted to heal
people
the impact that Magic Johnson when he
announced that he had HIV yeah what
impact did that have on you yeah that
was uh that was also a key moment that
it reinforced that feeling that uh that
um that I've just shared basically you
know in one of your Idols as well
uh announces that uh is HIV positive
which at the time to me is an 11 year
old kid what I understood that was he
was announcing a death sentence
um and then that implied his retirement
from basketball
um but luckily that that wasn't the case
but at that time I was like man I wish I
could uh work on on finding the the
solution the medication to to um to cure
AIDS to cure cancer so people don't have
to die at a young age so people can
leave a healthier and longer life did
you relay that to Magic when you met
first met with him
no I I related that story and on
different like Media or interviews uh
but I I I've never fully related it to
him even though I now I got to meet him
and kind of spend a little time with him
um but you know I always say that that
dream team also that 92 dream team has
impacted my life uh and has allowed me
to dream and and pursue that dream to
playing in the NBA amongst the best yeah
so that's the impact that the
professional athletes Elite athletes
have on children you don't you don't
realize but you become such a strong
influence you you really
you know excite and make these kids
dream around the world of becoming one
day in their lives you and we don't
realize it because the 92 Dream Team
happened only because we didn't win the
gold medal in 1988 we're like we're
gonna get that gold medal back we sent
in the heavy artillery and we blew away
everybody but you're part of the
byproduct and and you know Giannis and
uh the Joker and I mean Dirk all the
byproduct of the Dream Team I'm gonna
guess
yeah I think uh for sure it definitely
inspired so many kids uh especially
around my my age or Dirk's age was only
two years older than me
um Tony Parker's age as well through
years younger than me uh the the younger
ones probably didn't perceive that type
of impact that the 92 team had uh later
teams did probably and and the success I
feel of international players in the
league has influenced I think the the
new wave of great International Players
but at the same time I think that 92
Olympics just showed what the top what
the best players in the world would
could do the level that they would play
um which you know it was hard to follow
the NBA being overseas you know with a
time difference with the TV rides at the
time and uh the structure in the network
at the time right now it's a lot easier
you can watch anything anytime you know
it doesn't have to be live you can watch
it on your phone so it did different
different times so uh yeah but
definitely that team uh yeah influenced
heavily and inspired many Before I Let
You Go your thoughts on this year's
Lakers team how dangerous do you think
they can be
well there are I think they can be you
know really dangerous because uh you
know uh finally seem to be healthier
which is important and the trade
definitely helped uh chemistry and I
added some really uh really good pieces
that fit the core of the team better
than uh than what it was before and uh
and they're making a run they're they're
feel like you know that momentum that
confidence it's it's kind of growing uh
so they're able I mean yeah three games
left uh if they're able to to finish up
and win these three games they can
finish as high as fifth uh and now
now you've really become dangerous right
yes so you're you're in a pretty good
position you win you're pretty much
people counting you out and now you have
A.D rolling uh Lebron healthy and you
have a a core of players are hungry so
uh I just love what they what they've
been doing the way they've kind of
overcomed this whole this whole
situation this season you got your
jersey in the back what's the coolest
thing that you have in your office
ah
I don't know I guess uh you know the
Jersey some some basketballs have
milestones in my career
um you can collect other jerseys do you
have other I don't necessarily know I
don't uh I I have a couple but I don't
really collect them uh no kidding
yeah yeah I've I have like I said I have
a couple but I was always always had a
hard time like asking for you know
jerseys or signatures or stuff you know
what I did do actually one of the things
that I did do was to collect
um back when I was with the Lakers chip
Shaffer who was the athletic trainer
um he gave me a gift I saw I saw he had
this basketball on his in his office
at our practice facility
and I saw him he was like he showed it
to me it's like a Molten
uh from the 92 Olympics
you know in Barcelona I'm like wow it's
at you know 92 Olympics Barcelona it was
it was the official ball of the Olympics
and you say pow it was like here it is
but under one condition you have to get
all the signatures from all the players
of the 92 team
I said okay I'll do it you know I was so
excited I would carry that ball on the
road with me to uh because we were
playing Indiana and Larry Bird was the
the president and now we're playing
Houston and the reply Draxler was uh
commentator right uh the TV commentator
or you know we I took that ball with me
and I was and my wife gave me a surprise
for her wedding for my wedding gift uh
to finish off the the ones that I had
left which was I think Christian Ladner
I think Karl Malone John Stockton you
know the guys that weren't really around
the league
um so I and I finally got and that is
probably my my most precious possession
and that's the only thing that I kind of
went out of my way because it was so
special and I made a promise to chip
Schaefer uh gifted me that ball that's
great where is it
it's uh it's here I think it's here yes
you're supposed to know where it is
it's here it's here it's here okay
sometimes I mean I kept it in a safe for
a while because I was like oh my
precious possession I'm like uh it's
like I don't I mean it's such it's so
valuable because of the meaning that
we're talking about right we're talking
about that that team
um you know what it meant in the effect
that he had on my life and others and
the growth of the game just make sure
the kids aren't outside playing with it
okay I know no no it's all the way up up
high in a tough shell okay good I can't
reach it uh good we're safe uh good to
talk to you and congratulations and uh
hopefully it'll be be a memorable moment
emotional moment and uh well well worth
it
thank you so much it's been great Pau
Gasol